Salut à tous c’est pêcheur de trésors
Vous reconnaissez sûrement l'endroit.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui à Empuriabrava.
On est en compagnie de Quentin de Jade,
mais aussi.
Et vous vous y attendez surement ?
On a fait beaucoup
de vidéos avec eux, de Danny et de Wim,
Qui sont venus des Pays-Bas
jusqu'en Espagne aujourd'hui.
On espère que le spot va leur réserver
des surprises.
On a trouvé ici
des munitions de fusils à pompe,
des munitions de fusils de chasse
plutôt. On a trouvé aussi
un silencieux de pistolet,
mais on n'a pas trouvé les armes.
Maintenant il faut trouver les armes
Oui il faut
Il a dit qu'on espère.
Et voilà, en tout cas,
vous avez la chaîne de Wim,
qui est en description de la vidéo.
N'hésitez pas à jeter un coup d'œil.
D'habitude il trouve des choses
un petit peu mieux que ça.
C’est un briquet
Pas mal
Il reste quelques trucs.
C'est un coin sympa pour faire du kayak.
Il reste quelques trucs, je sent quelque chose
Après, y avait des gros objets aussi.
Tu te rappelles
qu'on avait peut être un peu laissé
Bonne chasse
Merci. Aurevoir
Il y a pas mal d’objets
qui font des bulles.
Oh oh !
On t'a porté chance ?
oui ! Oui
Il est beau
Il est chouette
Des bijoux
Découverte sympa mec !
Montre moi l'arrière
Un tube
Etonnant.
Oui il est petit ! Vous avez quelque chose?
Il y a un bon poids
C'est un piège à poissons ?
Pour faire pousser de la weed ?
Un système d’aération
Pour cultiver de la weed il a dit
Ok il faut un autre aimant
Il pense à un système d'aération
Non c’est une poubelle
Ah ouais, c'est juste une poubelle.
Ouais, comme celle là
On va voir
Attend, ne verse pas l'eau on va tout salir
Regardez
On va nettoyer après
Par contre, on peut la garder pour mettre les trouvailles
Ne vous inquiétez pas on nettoiera avec un seau
Ouais, on peut garder la poubelle
pour mettre la ferraille.
Bonne idée.
Merci. OK.
Sympa, ça nettoie
Un petit couteau.
Sympa, un couteau de poche
Et une boucle d'oreille.
Belles découvertes
C'est peut être un arme de meurtre
Ce n'est pas une arme de meurtre
Mais c'est un couteau sympa
Elle est où la mienne ?
Alors là,
c'est Baptiste qui me l'a piqué.
Coquin,
il m'a volé ma corde
et il n'a pas fait exprès.
En plus.
En plus, je pêchais mon aimant et sa corde
Moi d'abord
Qu'est-ce que tu as eu ?
Un couteau ?
Il a dû être détérioré avec l'eau salée
Ah non, sympa.
Deuxième couteau, alors Danny en a trouvé un
Le couteau d'un crime
Ouais, peut être.
Bravo Jade
Bonjour
C’est de la pêche à l’aimant
C’est interdit de pêcher ici
Oui mais ce n’est pas pour les poissons
C’est pour nettoyer
Ah ok
Et on emmène tout
Ok ok ok
Il y a l'homme du port
qui voyait ça et qui s'est dit
Mais, qu'est ce que vous faites ?
C'est interdit de pêcher.
Mais heureusement, en fait, ici
on nettoyait juste l'eau.
Donc il a dit que c'était OK,
qu'on pouvait continuer.
Donc visiblement la pêche.
Non, non, il a dit OK.
Donc visiblement
la pêche est légale en Espagne,
plus ou moins.
Est-ce que le monsieur va partir ?
Danny a trouvé un pistolet
Quentin, Quentin
Danny a un pistolet au bout de l'aimant,
mais faut que le gars parte.
On va attendre
Au pire moment
Oui
Donc là les gars, Danny a un pistolet au bout de l'aimant,
il a vu qu'il
avait un pistolet au bout de l'aimant
mais il se passe un truc de dingue,
Il y a le mec du port qui est là
Il part
Rasta est derrière le muret, il dort
Ok on peut le voir ?
OK, il a quelque chose, c'est
un revolver ?
Il est cassé
Il y a juste un bout
C'est un vieux, c'est un revolver
d'ordonnance.
Français je crois.
C’est un vrai au moins
Il faut trouver les autres morceaux
C’est un ancien revolver français
cool.
Je pense que c'est un revolver
1892 civil ou de l'armée
félicitation, ça commence bien.
Il m'a mi un blanc
Je t'ai mi un blanc ?
Incroyable,
on vient à peine de commencer la.
Manufacture d'armes de Saint-Etienne,
Il est comme neuf, Baptiste
Il n’était pas là la dernière fois qu’on a pêché ici
Il est tout neuf
Je pense que les autres morceaux sont aussi là
Faut trouver la seconde partie.
J’ai un autre morceau
C’est par ici
Quentin, il a trouvé des ressorts.
Il n’y est pas
C'était sûr.
Je pense que si.
Le ressort est là dedans normalement
Les plaquettes sont encore en bon état
C'est possible.
Danny est en feu !
Habituellement 1 seul lancé suffit pour trouver un revolver
Mais Danny va nous le faire en 10 fois
C'est super
Je pense que c'est celui là de ressortir.
Un bout de ciseau.
Seulement la moitié
C’est un bon spot
Mais il est vide
Un leurre de pêche.
Il est tout neuf.
Un leurre de pêche tout neuf
Mais le gars du port a dit que tu ne pouvais pas pêcher !
Celui-ci est joli
Un couteau
"La Fourmi"
"Fais bon profit"
De France encore
Encore de France
Je vais essayer de chercher
les autres morceaux de ce revolver.
Il y a le bateau qui dérive.
Ils ont oublié de jeter l'ancre, il faut leur dire
Il y en a un autre qui arrive droit vers nous
Ah non, il fait demi tour.
C'est Incroyable, je pense que le revolver n'y était pas quand on est venu.
Ah non, non, il est en bon état
super.
Une voiture de course.
Ce sera la miniature et le titre de la vidéo : On remonte une voiture de course
Elle vient de Chine
Je vais le re lancer alors
Un peu moins bien.
Je préfère le mien
Des clés.
Encore ! On a trouvé plein ici.
Plein de clés
Pas de paella tant qu'on n'a
pas trouvé la deuxième partie.
Tu n'auras pas de paella avant d'avoir trouvé les autres parties
Ok
On va essayer de l’avoir en entier
Yeah !
Oui ! Nous y sommes !
On a des clefs mais aussi...
Le canon
Cool !
Il est en bon état
Ouais, c'est le même
C'est une autre partie
du revolver
Merci pour le manche !
Il manque d’autres morceaux
Oui c’est comme ça
Ils ont coupé le canon aussi
Il tourne encore
pas de munitions à l’intérieur
Belle trouvaille
Même en Espagne !
Je suis content d’avoir eu celui-ci
Comme ça Danny garde l’autre et moi celui-là
Deux souvenirs de France
Si tu veux on peut échanger
Je préfère celui-là
Et moi j’aime le mien
Il y a le numéro de série
C’est honteux qu’il ait été cassé
Il manque encore beaucoup de parties
J’ai eu le ressort mais  il en manque aussi
Il est beau, le couteau qu'a trouvé Jade
Il y a du laiton
Avec une petite médaille.
Bon ben écoutez, le spot commence à se vider.
C'est vrai qu'on l'avait bien fait
la dernière fois aussi.
On a eu un peu de chance quand même,
parce que je pense que ce revolver
n'était pas dans l'eau.
Quand on l'a fait, la première fois.
Donc plutôt cool.
Voilà pour vous en dire plus
sur ce revolver.
Donc on pense que c'est 1892.
Alors le 1892 en France,
c'est assez particulier parce que c'est
un revolver assez puissant du XIXᵉ siècle.
Il a servi
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale
et même encore pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale pour certains.
Pour certains soldats, il y en a aussi
qui l'avaient pendant la guerre d'Algérie.
Donc c'est un revolver assez emblématique
de l'armée française.
Ce qui est intéressant aussi, c'est
qu'il était en détention libre
jusqu'à il y a quelque temps.
Puis il est passé dans les exceptions.
Donc c'est une des seules armes
du XIXᵉ siècle qui était en catégorie B,
donc interdite sans licence de tir.
Mais voilà, c'est super super intéressant
d'en trouver ici.
Voilà, c'est vrai
qu'en plus avec le canon scié,
ça montre qu'il a sûrement été utilisé
pour faire des braquages
Ou ce genre de choses.
Mais voilà donc le revolver à poudre
noire.
Allez, Quentin nettoie le spot
On n'est pas en France,
alors on fait encore plus attention.
Déjà que les français ont pas la meilleure
réputation à la frontière de l'Espagne.
Pas vrai mon petit ?
Voilà.
Bon appétit à tous.
On va faire une petite paella.
Pendant la pause de pêche à l'aimant
On espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
En tout cas, nous, on a qui aimé cette
paella et c'est le principal.
Quand j'étais avec eux, l'autre fois, c'est moi
qui ai trouvé tous les meilleurs trucs.
La dernière fois c'était Jade
Et je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
ils vont prendre leur revanche.
Mais bon, tant mieux, ça arrive, c'est le jeu de la pêche ça.
Alors à la semaine prochaine,
pour une nouvelle vidéo
de pêche à l'aimant
Tu peux attaquer Jade